i'm lizzy daly your host and i am super
thrilled to be back for yet
another epic live today
if you're new around here welcome
welcome welcome you are in for a treat
today
if you've been following over the past
few weeks let me tell you we have been
on quite a journey across the world
chatting to experts and scientists
learning all about fascinating science
and
natural world behaviors and new sciences
happening around the world we've met
with
dr ray ryan grant talking about how to
be a bear
biologist last week we were in hungary
learning about the meadow viper and how
venom the world's deadliest venom can be
applied
to us and our world and medicine in the
most
mind-blowing ways um now if you are new
around here hello i'm
a biologist and wildlife tv presenter so
thrilled to be hosting
today's live with our very special guest
who i'll introduce very shortly but i
can tell you
that today we're going to be heading
below the waves this
is probably a topic that i absolutely is
probably one of my favorites to be
honest i'm not a marine biologist but i
have an
absolute love for the ocean so if you do
as well
this is your opportunity to get your
questions into myself
and our expert today live all about
coral i'm sure you have massive
questions about coral
what is coral how does coral reproduce
where can you find coral on the planet
pretty much anywhere but coral is a
mind-blowing incredible incredible
marine invertebrate that there is so
much more to learn about
one of my favorite things to see on a
dive is always the
vibrant colors of coral and yes you get
vibrant
rock coral even here rainy whales here
in the uk where i'm coming to you live
in fact
in the uk i have a bit of a love for
marine invertebrates in general
this was me diving with the giant
jellyfish just last year um and it was a
real
giant and just a fascinating
group that perhaps many of us have
misconceptions about
um as i said many may not even know what
coral is so today
is all about delving into the science
and and the information about
some of the most widespread diverse and
vibrant corals
of our planet so who are we talking to
today well we are chatting to dr erica
mosley who is all about coral she's a
marine biologist she's spent the
past 15 years actually studying coral
she's a national
geographic explorer and she about
well a number of years ago started a
non-profit organization called the
hydras because
she herself has big questions about
coral and so wanted to share information
about this whole group
and to us to you and i to the wider
public to kids
and education kits and vr she basically
is bringing coral
to us in classrooms in our living rooms
to our home so we can all learn more
about coal and experience it now
very excitingly at the end of today's
live
we are going to show you how you
yourself can go on a vr
dive deep into the ocean to meet coral
but before we do that
we've got lots to learn i've got lots to
learn and erica is actually with us here
now
live erica hello hello lizzy
i am so excited to go diving with you
today thanks so much for having me
do you know i've been looking forward to
this one erica because i have a serious
love for the ocean
but i actually have many many questions
about coral so
i guess an obvious place to start is you
and your journey
in the past 15 years incredible
incredible work why
coral it's a great question
coral are just absolutely fascinating
animals
and as you mentioned they're found all
over the world there are corals that are
deep they're corals that are in cold
water even up in
alaska they exist from the equator to
the poles
and they are living animals but they
also have
characteristics of plants so they have
partnerships with types of algae to
photosynthesize to
gain energy and they can turn
sea water into rock i mean they're
miraculous and
the rock that they build creates these
amazing geological structures that
provide habitat
so the tropical shallower water coral
reefs are the ones that i've been
exploring for the last 15 to 20 years
as a scientist and as a diver and this
the more i learn
the more enamored i become because
they're so beautiful
and so fascinating absolutely and yeah
as we i was reading about this um before
we went live you know over 6 000
different species of coral but
i know you specifically look at how
changing oceans can
can impact corals and how they develop
and we'll talk about how they reproduce
as well very
shortly but um you touched on it just
then actually
what is coral i know our audience are
really hot on
this kind of thing and they're really
knowledgeable but if you could describe
coral as an organism what actually is it
yeah so corals are relatives of
jellyfish
and anemones so they're soft bodied and
they're made up of lots of little polyps
so if you can imagine
a central mouth surrounded by multiple
tentacles
and those soft body polyps are what
secrete
calcium carbonate structure so the
aragonite or limestone
that builds the habitat so here we have
a still
image of our 360 film that sort of shows
the structure and they're colonial
animals
that can bud and clone and grow
while laying down rock essentially and
so even though they're made up of very
small
individual polyps they can build massive
structures
that cover large areas
yeah i mean even just thinking about
that it is a fascinating um
um organism to look at um but you spent
a lot of time on the great barrier
reef right tell us more about that that
must be the place for coral
surely absolutely it's the largest reef
system
in the world the great barrier reef runs
about 2 000 kilometers long
and covers a large area it's a marine
protected area in australia
and i've been so fortunate to spend so
much time
on islands and underwater and on boats
exploring and diving in these amazing
places
and it's just been a joy and a privilege
and i've also seen these places change
pretty rapidly over just
you know the few years that i've been
exploring them
wow and yeah i can't even imagine how
much you've seen
and but if you i'm just thinking of the
general diver now i mean for anyone
who isn't a coral expert like you you
may hold onto a reef and see just a load
of colors
how many coral species can you get in in
one reef say
if you go on one dive absolutely so
the hard coral so the reef building
corals
also known as sclerotinians there are
about a thousand species around the
world
at places on the great barrier reef you
might see
400 or so but if you go into places like
indonesia where the species richness is
the highest
on earth you'll get even more than that
and
usually the further you go away from the
equator
the fewer types of species there are
even if the abundance is high wow
okay that's interesting is is there a
reason behind that at all
yes and so so much of coral reefs
and where they're successful has to do
with suitable habitat
and suitable parameters so for instance
the aragonite saturation in the water
has to be right so the water chemistry
has to be conducive to coral growth the
temperatures
have to be within a certain range that
allows for them to grow
survive and reproduce over many
generations
and for the coral reefs that i generally
work with
you need relatively shallow water
so like on the great barrier reef you
have this amazing continental shelf that
goes out many miles
that doesn't go straight into deep water
so allows for
access to sunlight for those species
that
need sunlight to generate energy
absolutely fascinating and we'll talk a
little bit more about how that kind of
fits into your
really important research a little bit
later on um i've got to ask
do you have a favorite coral i know what
mine is the only local
you must have one surely i have a few
favorites
um i really like stylophora pistolata
because it's just really vibrant colors
um it has sort of a fuzzy appearance
because their tentacles are usually
extended
and it can be bright pink bright blue
and it's just absolutely beautiful i
also really like goniastria fabulous
which exists usually at high latitudes
and have unique ways
of reproducing and surviving in really
difficult places
so i like the spirit of that species
yeah yeah
my uh favorite coral is um not
scientific name here it's cup coral
which is a lot easier to spell for the
team in the chat
try and spell out those two species but
um love cup corals um on my on my local
coaster
fabulous about coral is that they don't
necessarily have to be
in big colonies they can be on their own
fighting the elements
and sort of singular polyps in cold and
deep areas
yeah they're tough they are they're
tough and i mean
it's here in the uk we don't have the
best diving spots but we've still got
coral which says a lot about how
brilliant they really are
um okay so i mean that's kind of looking
at the the basis
of of what coral is and silly question
what does coral eat
how does it work how what's their
ecology like
great question so with these uh hard
reef building corals most of the energy
that they
get to survive comes from their
photosynthesizing
algae partners so a plant-like organism
that actually
lives in their soft tissues of those
polyps
and they generate energy from the sun
essentially just like a plant on land
would do and that energy
leads to about 70 percent of what the
coral needs to survive
and then the tentacles to make up the
remaining
energy that they need can capture small
organisms from the water in what's
called you know
collect and just collection and sort of
filter feeding of
different particles of things that just
happen to be floating by because corals
can't really
move around and hunt they just stay in
one place they're basically cemented to
the sea floor
while the water current brings food
i guess the more healthy the ocean the
larger the reef eventually
it depends it really just matters
what the parameters are and how certain
species are locally adapted
to those environments although
in recent years especially in the
caribbean and on the great barrier
reef and other large reef systems we
have seen them declining
pretty rapidly over recent years from
the combined effects of a lot of things
including overfishing habitat
destruction
pollution and also rising ocean
temperatures are making it pretty
stressful for coral animals at the
moment
yeah absolutely i'm sure many people
watching have um heard about the decline
of coral and i'm sure you'll tell us
more about it shortly um so you've
worked extensively on coral across the
world
um fascinating uh research and your
application with
vr and connecting the sword coral is
fabulous but before we go into that
um i have a question for you is and it's
really kind of an important one
right in terms of how life is formed and
continues
how does coral actually reproduce it's a
question that's been
on my mind now for a wee while well this
is my area of expertise and it's my
favorite thing to talk about
so as i mentioned coral that i
generally study are hard corals as
opposed to soft corals which are
sort of the sea fans that yeah that move
with the water current but the hard
girls build the reef
and so when i study coral reproduction
i like to call it hard coral porn
what happens is in order for these
ecosystems to regenerate
and persevere and continue especially
following disturbances like
cyclones or bleaching events or any kind
of habitat destruction
you need these amazing mechanisms to
replenish themselves
so corals can reproduce reproduce
asexually as well so they can clone
themselves and that's how they actually
build the reef
but the sexual reproduction is
fascinating
so imagine you're a coral you're
basically cemented to the seafloor
you can't move around yeah
you're doing a great job how do you find
a mate when it's time to breed
and it's not like a tree or a flower
because there are no pollinators in the
ocean
right what's happened is corals have
developed this amazing synchronicity
where cued by lunar cycles and water
temperatures
they all spawn at the same time
so over the course of a few nights
following
a full moon in the springtime
after the sun goes down corals release
these bundles that can be pink or red or
orange
filled with egg and sperm so these are
the hermaphroditic species the ones that
have both
male and female gametes and those
bundles are positively buoyant so they
float up to the surface
and break apart from the water movement
and then can cross
fertilize with other genetically
distinct
colonies from other areas and that
fertilized egg over the course of a few
days
will develop into a coral larvae
which can then when it's ready settle
back down
on a reef and metamorphose into
a new polyp and then grow and grow
cloning itself
to build the reef on top of
its ancestors essentially and it's known
as the most
synchronized sex event in the whole
animal kingdom and it's just such
a privilege to be diving during this and
so that image you just saw
just imagine all of these orbs
of colorful egg and sperm bundles
floating around you
it's like oh yeah oh my gosh
billions and billions and billions just
a table coral or in a crop red this big
can produce about a million eggs so
imagine that
for many miles it's just a bonanza and
there are a lot of fish
that are spawning around that time giant
clams are spawning around that time
i've been on island research stations
that are also bird sanctuaries and
they're nesting
and the turtles are coming up on the
beach to lay eggs so it's a very sexy
time on the reef
sexy time on the reef hard coral port i
just it's actually mind blowing the way
that animals have this way of kind of
still being able to reproduce despite
how they live you know you hear about
sperm casting it's kind of like an
extreme version of that isn't it
launching across the ocean honestly that
is mind blowing
so just just that is fascinating um a
particular species
will release we'll go into that spawning
event and that
sperm for that species will fertilize
the same species but perhaps
in a completely different geographical
region is that right
absolutely and the currents can take
that spawn and that larvae many many
miles like thousands of kilometers
depending on the water motion because
they're just passive drifters and
they're going
where the ocean takes them essentially
wow
wow you have the coolest job ever so
interesting that is absolutely
fascinating and and
do you have some coal with you because
we've talked about some species
and what i love about this is this
actually isn't real coral
this is a reproduction of a real colony
from hawaii so mike and i
we went diving and took lots and lots of
pictures of this
living coral on the reef and we were
able to stitch it together
in a method of reality capture called
photogrammetry
and we were able to turn that into a
digital 3d model
that is informative because it gives us
things like volume and surface area to
understand its ecology even better
and we could 3d print it and so this
coral
we hope is still alive and well on the
reef so this is a non-destructive way
to teach about coral to show
just how beautiful and interesting they
are we also painted this particular
colony a certain way
to visualize like for a coral to
partially bleach
okay color we also have
a pretty amazing ability to 3d print
wow this didn't require the painting
yes so this is a pasta opera mandrina
okay pretty small colony uh of course
it's scale so it's actually a lot
smaller than it is
in the ocean but what was really cool is
when we printed this
it printed as its natural colors
okay so why don't you paint it and so
wow
so this would make amazing decoration
we're hoping to
sort of replace the need to decorate
with coral skeletons which can be
damaging
especially especially for areas that
are already affected and we also have
these special corals that we've painted
a special kind of paint
to demonstrate that areas of
the reef are turning white when you they
poke warm water bleaching hey
that's bleaching basically you are
showing what happens when when bleaching
occurs absolutely
so what's happening is when corals
are experiencing higher than normal sea
surface temperatures
they get kind of stressed out and many
corals are living at their upper thermal
limits
and when they get stressed they expel
their algal symbionts so the zoos and
philly that live in their tissues and
give them their energy
and without those you can see through
the coral polyp
to their white calcium carbonate
skeleton and so it looks
white and that's why it's called
bleaching it's not because
people are pouring bleach into the water
it's just a descriptive term and when
you see a white reef
it doesn't mean that it's dead but it
does mean that it's starving
usually bleached reefs become overtaken
by
seaweed and it's really hard for reefs
to recover and grow back
and so any way that we can work on
bringing color
back to the reef it has a shot of
continuing and persevering and corals
can recover
they can and we've seen that we just
have to let them and give them that
space
absolutely and talking about bringing
coral back to the reef you bring
you're bringing sorry colour not coral
or colourful coral to be honest
you're bringing you're bringing both to
us as well through vr so
i mentioned the non-profit organization
the hydras what a brilliant idea about
using vr because so many of us
you know i'm sat in my garden right now
you know i'm not able to go
however many feet down to see beautiful
coral so tell us more about that i'm
super excited about this
uh well lizzy one of my favorite things
to do
in the world is to take people diving
i just love being underwater and even
more i love taking people underwater
with me
i'm a dive master so i've lead dives for
many years i'm a kayak guide i love
taking people
into the ocean in some way however i
can't take everyone to the ocean
and so i'm really interested in using
scalable technologies
to bring the ocean to everybody because
there's such a disconnect
between living on land and life
underwater for a lot of reasons like for
instance we can't breathe underwater and
not everyone can swim and it's not
always
available for people to visit the ocean
and so
what's so exciting is this medium of
virtual reality of this electronic
immersion
can generate presence and agency and
make you
feel like you're there and so it's that
emotional connection that can really
bridge the disconnection
between scientific discovery and public
understanding plus it's just so joyful
so here's a picture of me diving in the
republic of palau
with our amazing underwater cameraman
and a producer
on our vr film and he's holding this
incredible camera
called the virtual 2 and essentially
it's 13 different
individual cameras mounted together in
an underwater housing
and was able to shoot 60 frames per
second in 4k
and they're mounted in pairs so that we
can generate
depth in the end what an epic bit of kit
look at that that is absolutely fabulous
and and um that's what i mean all the
pictures shown here most of them shown
in this chat by the way everyone
watching
um this is what you'll be able to
experience at the end when you
tell them when we share you a little bit
more about going on that vr dive but um
i mean i mean for you this must be a
real opportunity to
as you say create that connection
absolutely
and i love talking to people after they
go
virtually diving with me because in the
experience i'm actually your dive guide
and i get to signal to you i point out
turtles
and signals i don't get feel so
connected to people and when they come
out of the experience
often i get to hear really cool stories
about their
ocean journey and whether they've ever
gone diving or tide pooling or spend
time at the beach
and i've been so just joyed
by how many people have their own
connection to the ocean in a
really specific and unique way and not
only is the ocean beautiful
and an amazing place to be we also all
rely on it healthy oceans healthy people
yeah absolutely i do want to come come
on to that a little bit later and how
we'll
very much connected to the ocean even if
it's not right in front of us but for
you in this vr
what has been do you think the most
valuable thing for people going on these
dives i just love
looking around and feeling submerged
because
oceans and vr are such a match made in
heaven
because when you're floating you can
look up and down and all
around you when you're kind of walking
on land you don't look
down as much for instance and just
seeing a school of fish
surrounding you and seeing the reef
sort of building over you and these big
cathedral-like structures
is really incredible and to feel like
you're there
and rather than you know watching a
video of a scientist
or a diver exploring a reef you
get to become the scientist or the diver
and explore
yourself um absolutely fascinating
um now the reefs is only part of the
picture right
i'm sure you've seen so much on and
around reefs but let's talk a little bit
about how it works its way
up up the food chain if you like up the
system of bigger life what's your what's
been your favorite moment in a reef oh
my gosh
so coral reefs are like the rain forest
of the ocean
they cover less than one percent of the
whole seafloor but
harbor about a quarter of all marine
biodiversity and so that includes the
smallest
colorful sea slug or nudibranch and
crabs
and mantis shrimp up to
fish and bigger fish and then
turtles and sharks and whales and
dolphins and
everything that comes through a reef
uses it as habitat
or as food and spends some portion of
their life cycle
on it and so i've been so lucky i could
stare at
just like a meter by meter area of reef
for hours because there's so
much going on there's competition
there's
predator prey relationships i can i can
look
very close and just get totally stuck
there but when you zoom out you're like
oh there's a shark behind me
and getting to swim with gray reef
sharks or
whale sharks is just a total joy and
there have even been times where i've
been diving and hear
humpback whales singing and the way
sound works under water is i it feels
like it's all around me
and it feels like i'm swimming with them
and it's just that
immersion and that experience of
weightlessness and floating
is absolutely magical and to be able to
swim with and and visit this
yeah biodiversity is such a privilege
absolutely yeah it really really is um
lovely picture of you there by the way
with a manta oh must be just absolutely
awesome
and and to make all those connections is
super important you know
i i may be wrong in saying this but i i
do feel like there's a bit of a
misconception about a reef you know
it's kind of just stuck to the bottom of
the sea and of course they're very
beautiful to look at but they're
the power in which they kind of harness
with as a food system
as a habitat for so many um so much life
on this earth
is very misunderstood so have i mean
what do you think is the biggest
misconception about coral
well as you say i think um not everyone
realizes that they're living animals
they kind of we're just swimming by they
look like they're rocks
or they might be plants because they
seem to be still
with our sort of perception of of time
and movement but again if you put a
time-lapse
camera the wreath is so big different
coral colonies are fighting with each
other
they're moving around they're extending
their polyps they're
moving with the water currents they are
reproducing
they're migrating because they have that
life history stage where they can float
through the water and
settle somewhere else so they're
incredibly dynamic
they're incredibly just lively just not
in the way that we
generally perceive animals because when
we think of animals like they run around
and chase each other and climb trees
but they are living things and so that
means that the way that we
treat them and the way that we utilize
them especially for
for resources like fish and any other
kind of food or pharmaceuticals
we really need to take care of them
because
they are living and so much depends on
them including us
absolutely so let's talk about that i
mean what what for you
the have you found to be the main
threats to our corals of the
of the earth and across all our oceans
well if we talk
very generally and this includes deep
corals and cold water corals
things like dredging and habitat
destruction
and pollution is really damaging so off
the coast of california here in the
colder deeper water we have these
amazing diverse
coral communities that really rely on
the local protection
so luckily a lot of that is really well
cared for
that's not the case everywhere and the
issue with tropical shallow water coral
reefs is we've lost about
half of those reefs over the last 50
years
and that is due to just the combined
effects the
cumulative effects of direct
human disturbances overfishing because
when you take
too many things out of the food web it
sort of ripples down
to the reef and vice versa so if you
destroy the reef or if the reef bleaches
the fish and the other invertebrates and
everything else that goes up the food
chain
really relies on it so unfortunately a
lot of places in the world are sort of
getting
hit from all sides yeah yeah and um
is there a particular reef i mean you
spent so much time on the great barrier
reef but
is there a particular reef that's really
facing bigger challenges than others
because as you say lots going on on our
oceans right now it's kind of hard to
understand um on a big scale
yeah well unfortunately there isn't just
one reef
that's under a lot of threat the
bleaching event from
2015 to 2017 was the
largest most widespread severe
event ever recorded and it went it hit
every ocean so there are shallow water
coral reefs
in eastern africa throughout the indian
ocean
throughout indonesia japan
the great barrier reef is just the
caribbean in hawaii is just hit
everywhere and it's been very dramatic
to see
just in a few weeks a reef that's been
there for hundreds and
or thousands of years turn white and
just die
in a very short amount of time and that
was
just for those who may not know what
what happened during that bleaching
event um
could you break down some of the causes
behind that yeah so
usually these bleaching events coincide
with el nino
events where temperatures are higher
than normal we have these
warm water anomalies and sometimes
storms come through
and prevent the sort of stagnant warm
water from
from just kind of staying still and warm
and those elevated temperatures over a
you know a couple of weeks
cause corals to get stressed out and the
algae that lives inside them are over
oxidizing and that's really not good for
the coral and so they expel
their symbionts and that they need them
to survive and so
it's really a matter of higher than
normal temperatures
with the fact that corals that are
better protected on a local level
have a better chance at recovering
like i mentioned corals can recover i've
seen a wreath completely wiped out by a
cyclone and within
about five to ten years it was growing
back it's amazing what girls can do
thanks to those amazing reproductive
mechanisms
so of course that is absolutely
incredible how sensitive
are our corals and our coral reefs um
we talk about changing oceans all the
time and um
as we're seeing that more and more in
fact actually let's talk about some of
those changes and some of your research
looking into that first
and and then we can go a little bit more
into how sensitive they are because it's
something i'm always thinking i'm
thinking of constantly you know
how how we can do our bit to help save
coral but it's um
it's hard to kind of uh truly get to the
bottom of
of that exact issue absolutely and so
corals are often called sensitive but i
think that's a little unfair
because we're putting a lot on them
and i survived warmer periods in our
earth history and they've migrated to
higher latitudes and we have this
amazing geological record
right now the issue is the rate of
changing oceans
not only the the water chemistry and the
water temperature changing but also
all of the pollution all of the
overfishing
all of the habitat destruction that's
piling onto that
it's just a lot for corals to overcome
okay yeah and um i mean that that in
itself is is
really interesting because you do read
all the time sensitive corals sensitive
coral reefs put them
there's so much to do and are you
positive about the future about corals
please say yes
i have so much ocean optimism and what i
love seeing
is the incredible work being done around
the world
by community leaders by ocean advocates
by scientists by educators
who are taking a really amazing
multi-disciplinary approach
to addressing these issues and
addressing it from a human-centered lens
because in the end it's all about our
relationship to the ocean and whether
we can continue relying on these
ecosystems that we need to survive
yeah and you must have seen how close
our relationship in some
coastal communities is with with coral
um do you have any kind of stories
about that or any particular places that
you've been where you've seen this kind
of really
intricate relationship between people
and coral absolutely
i've met a number of artisanal fishermen
or fishers that you know go out fishing
every day
and thanks to healthy reefs they have
food to feed their family or sell
and they're also amazing tourism
industries so a number of people i've
met
know the reef far better than i ever
could and they've grown up on it and
they've explored it
and they've seen changes themselves and
they also know that their livelihoods
are impacted
by tourism and the health of the reef
and so they're very driven
to to protect it and keep it healthy
not only because it's the right thing to
do and it's important for the ecology
and the beauty of the reef but it's
something that they directly depend
on you can have a close relationship
alongside these ecosystems and these
habitats sustainably right for the
future
absolutely love it love the ocean
optimism as well i'm gonna use that i
think that's a really lovely one
and okay we have questions flooding in
and some really great ones um
i'm not surprised by that at all so
let's let's actually head over to some
of those questions
um we have one here how quickly do they
grow and how long can a coral live for
good question to set us off great
question and so
that completely depends so deep
water cold corals are very slow growing
where
um staghorn coral so like these
branching ones
or the genus acropora are known as sort
of the weedier species and they grow
quickly
and they're known to be some of the
first colonizers of a reef that's been
damaged
whereas a bolder coral or a brain coral
might grow
more slowly and of course there are
trade-offs to that so the slower growing
species
are generally more resistant to changing
oceans
as opposed to fast growing acroporids or
branching corals which are generally the
most vulnerable
okay so we're seeing that kind of across
species then we're seeing a
faster decline in those species that are
are faster growing
that is exactly right and with
regards to the question of how long do
they live that's actually a complicated
question
complicated answer because
corals are always cloning and that
genotype gets replicated
in a way they just keep going and going
unless they're like
completely stopped so in some way you
might see them as immortal
if they're just growing on the ancestors
so if you look at a coral reef
the surface of it the skin of it is that
soft bodied
living animal and everything below is
the calcium carbonate skeleton that has
built up
over generations and generations and
a single coral polyp can also be eaten
by
a fish and so they have natural
predators it's all part of this
the ecosystem and they'll just keep
living until
you stop them which we're doing it's
like a multi-layered cake
of coral coral goodness this is just
it's mind-blowing everyone this is
incredible um
oh great question kevin please discuss
reproduction by cuttings to
propagate new corals nice nice question
there
great question so there are a lot of
amazing practitioners
that are experimenting and trying
coral gardening or coral planting so if
i were to take a little piece
of this coral branch well not this
because it's 3d printed model
and gently place it or grow it in the
lab or put it back on the reef and use
special glue
it can keep growing and it can
have done this to create sort of coral
gardens in areas that have been damaged
of course my big question is will it get
damaged again
the same way the first reef was damaged
and so
there's a lot of interesting research
into how to do these
these fragments of coral and micro
fragging is what it's called to increase
the rates
of growth and maybe even breed thermally
tolerant
uh species that allow the corals to
withstand greater stress okay that's
fascinating
so that initial coral will still will
still survive as a coral just part of
that will then be
essentially sustainably taken elsewhere
for regrowth
absolutely awesome and i have i've have
heard of that before but um
you know just the power of that i guess
the future of our corals those
particularly in decline would just be
awesome you know if they could take that
forward um how do corals contribute to
at
the animal kingdom and we've touched on
this briefly from large and small
could you sum that up it's a bit of a
tricky one i mean the animal kingdom is
so
huge you specify
to the ocean and i mean from a
scientist's point of view they're just
so unique
and fascinating and from the corals
point
of view they support so much they
are the ecosystem engineers
of these habitats and they build the
three-dimensional structure
that allow little fish or little crabs
or shrimp
to hide in them and that that rugosity
as it's called
is what allows for so much life
on the reef and i mentioned this before
but about 25 percent of
all marine animals rely
on coral reefs because they create this
habitat
i mean that is that is the fact isn't it
that that figure is 25
that is that says it all incredibly
important um
fabulous questions coming in okay we've
got another one here
um can coral animals die from man-made
pollution in the sea
and how are we recycling microplastics
in the ocean
so let's start with the first one great
question and the answer is yes
unfortunately a lot of the things we put
into the ocean are affecting it
it used to be thought that dilution was
the solution to pollution
but we find out that you know even in a
place as big as the entire ocean
is still affected by us putting our
waste
into it an example of that is fertilizer
runoff
or runoff from cities so any kind of
waste
can create an over abundance of
nutrients in the water
that can cause algae blooms or algae
blooms and
that can smother corals because they
need that access to light
and so you have these sort of ripple
effects the domino effects
of putting extra stuff in the ocean that
we might not have thought
it has these effects and so
unfortunately in a lot of places that
don't have proper waste treatment
or are stirring up sediment the corals
get covered
by algae or by um sediments and they
just can't continue to survive
that's a really good point you know do
you think we're fully aware of the
impact
we may be having on our corals i i don't
think as
much as we should it's you know it's a
very much out of sight out of mind
problem
um quite often we just see the surface
of the ocean and it looks calm and
beautiful
but there's a lot going beneath the
surface and the things that we do on
land
truly impact what's happening underwater
and fast changes as well
and of course that question about
microplastics and the impact of of
plastics
um in our ocean does plastic impact
coral at all
it does unfortunately my um
colleagues and co-founders of the hydras
nora she discovered
that coral animals are actually
ingesting microplastics
in the lab where she put microplastics
in the water that the corals feed on
because as i mentioned they also
you know take the water with their
tentacles and they're ingesting
microplastics and that can really
be disruptive to their ability to feed
and survive
yeah sure and i know there's a number of
um cleanup operations for for
microplastics but microplastics is one
of the biggest social
uh problems in that ocean um whether
they're primary or secondary and
it's a really kind of hard to grasp uh
issue that our oceans are
facing and unfortunately it's sad to
hear that our corals are facing those
issues as well
um is the damage to our reefs really
reversible
and taking co2 actively out of the air
is nearly impossible
um they're a physicist they say and what
can oh there's lots of questions here so
let's start with those fears
i mean ocean optimism you've talked
about that i'm an ocean optimist
now definitely but can we reverse some
of that damage really
yeah well i really want to thank that
physicist for that question
because it really does come come down to
that in a lot of ways so when it comes
to
addressing the warming oceans we really
need to address the fact
that there's an excess amount of co2 in
our atmosphere
which also gets absorbed into our ocean
and changes the chemistry and the ocean
is warming
and so i would want both mitigation
and adaptation and so when it comes to
sequestration as our physicist
physicist friend points out it is very
difficult um
in terms of taking co2 out of the
atmosphere or out of the ocean
and there's a lot of really fascinating
research that's going into that and i'm
i'm excited to see how that evolves
oh yeah i think we should uh address the
root of the problem
and as an international community of
people
really take a stand in preventing excess
co2
being released into the atmosphere i
think it's really up to us to use our
powers as citizens and consumers
to prevent that from getting worse and
corals can recover
again if we tackle these problems
we have a really good chance of keeping
corals and people healthy
it's a good question i think largely
because many of us see you know want to
do our bit but it's hard to actually
make that positive impact
but the initial thing is to to slow down
the way that we are consuming the way
that we live so
you know it's um it's a question which i
think um we should be
not asking yet we should first be asking
the question you know what can i do
every day to really as a consumer make
those changes to slow down that process
but
nevertheless um good to have a physicist
on that's great
um what can young people do to help um
protect our oceans
great question i love that question and
i'm just hearing a bunch of new
solutions and ideas every day
and i want to preface this by saying
that
we all need to decide on our own what
works for us
what we can i feel like a lot of people
including myself sometimes get
overwhelmed with not being able to do
everything all the time but there are so
many small ways that we can each
protect our ocean every day and one of
my favorite sayings
is don't let perfect be the enemy of
good so what i'm about to say
you don't have to do it all i'm just
giving options
um one of the best ways that you can
protect the health of our oceans and the
health
of people that rely on them is to think
about how you source your seafood
so sustainably source seafood means
better jobs more jobs and
healthier fish and more fish and so
a really great resource that i highly
recommend
is the monterey bay aquarium seafood
watch program
and they have a free app so if you're
ordering food or buying food you can
enter
the sort of fish that you're interested
in where it comes from and learn more
about whether it's a quote unquote green
choice which i think should be a blue
choice
or a red choice which may be something
you want to avoid because it can be
caught through damaging methods that
affect affect reefs or other parts
of the ocean another thing is to really
think about
your waste and how much
marine waste you're producing whether
it's related to your community's
recycling programs or
waste treatment or you as an individual
and then finding ways to reduce your
your carbon footprint and like i said
it's a little bit
hard to go completely carbon neutral but
there are ways
you can reduce there are ways that you
can offset
and all of the choices really really add
up
and like i mentioned before use your
power as
a consumer support businesses that are
ocean-minded or sustainably-minded
and use your power as a citizen vote for
ways to protect the ocean
absolutely super important uh one just
at the end there
and um i would also add on to that
actually
go to hydras and learn more about and
get learn about them and about their
dives go on a vr dive
and um and just get to know the ocean
get to know the nitty gritty science
behind it if you're interested in it
you will learn everything there is to
know with erica herself
and one last question before we go um do
you think it is possible to use
artificial intelligence technologies
like machine learning and deep learning
to help save coral reefs good question
admit it i have a question and there are
so many brilliant people
working on that right now and so for
instance um
dr grace young is working on machine
learning
to help track ocean health and help
identify fish species and we have so
much amazing data
and big data is such a great way
to monitor and understand and study our
ocean so that we know how to better
protect it
and absolutely there's there are so many
great examples of machine learning and
ai
um the first thing that comes to mind
actually
is you might have seen that photo of me
diving with the manta ray
and you could see that there were
markings on its belly and those markings
are unique for each individual
like a fingerprint or a qr code and so
for scientists to track these animals
they don't need to put a physical
tagging device on them
they just need to use their photos and
all of these photos together
thousands and thousands collected around
the world can
use machine learning algorithms to
identify
and track these individuals so that we
can better understand this threatens an
endangered species
fantastic the power of technology see
slowly learning more about our oceans
and learning how to protect them
and cause it you have been absolutely
fantastic it's been so good to chat to
you
and to learn more about your work your
research
um before we go really exciting i'm
hoping everyone
is clinging on with excitement because
how can people go on a vr dive tell us
and um
and i'm pretty sure we got a code or
something for them right yes
so i just made that reference to the qr
codes on the
manta bellies and in a moment we're
going to show
a graphic of a manta ray with a qr code
so what you can do
is take your smartphone and open your
camera app
and when you see the qr code the link
should just pop up
and you can open it make sure you open
it in the youtube app
and you'll be able to see our 360 dive
which is called immerse that my amazing
team at the hydras has developed
and you can watch it on your phone in a
few different ways you can move your
phone around
and see the reef around you as you move
it love it or you can drag with your
finger
or if you happen to have a cardboard
viewer like this
i put a little mask sticker on it you
can
you can press the special vr icon
in the app it will then turn into a
split screen which you can turn
sideways and put into your vr viewer
like this total
emergency going piping
it's a real life dive absolutely
fantastic
um erica thank you ever so much for
coming on live
um i can't wait to see what you're up to
next i'll be going on a vr dive
right after this anything else you'd
like to add before we sign off
just thank you so much for coming diving
with me
yeah it's been absolutely wonderful and
you do fantastic work and i'm sure
everyone enjoy
and on here has enjoyed it and has
enjoyed listening to you so thank you
um and thank you all for tuning in you
can see that qr code
right now go go go we hope you've
enjoyed it
um from spawning mass incredible
coral sporting events to learning about
the intricate cup
corals that you may have on your reefs
on your doorstep and going on a vr
dive with erica herself i mean what an
incredible live
uh this has been my mind has been blown
about these incredible marine
invertebrates and it seems we have lots
and lots to do to help conserve them so
if you're passionate about
the ocean coral reefs or anything that
erica has talked about today please
go on that qr code now go on a vr dive
and uh we'll see you again
here on the channel next week same time
bye